Traduttore: Martina Cavallo
Revisore: Angélica Victoria
Speleologo.
Una parola un po' difficile
da pronunciare.
Significa semplicemente una persona
che per curiosità, per passione,
per ricerca scientifica decide
di avventurarsi in quel mondo sotterraneo
che si sviluppa sotto i nostri piedi,
all'interno delle montagne.
È un luogo che di fatto rappresenta
una delle ultime frontiere esplorative
del nostro pianeta.
Ed è difficile da immaginare,
è veramente difficile da definire.
Se pensate alla geografia,
una cartina geografica rappresenta solo
la superficie del nostro pianeta.
Mentre il mondo sotterraneo è un mondo
che sostanzialmente noi ignoriamo.
È come se non ci fosse.
Per questo a me piace chiamarlo
"Il continente buio".
Ma prima di portarvi a vedere
un po' delle meraviglie
di queste terre della notte,
vi voglio confessare una cosa.
Quando ero bambino avevo
una paura tremenda del buio.
Mi consola il fatto che questa paura
è stata condivisa probabilmente
con tantissimi bambini.
E se ci pensate,
la vita comincia nel grembo materno
proprio nell'oscurità
ed è quell'oscurità
che ci separa dal mondo esterno,
ci difende da ciò
che ancora non conosciamo,
da ciò che ancora non ci è stato svelato.
Nascere e vivere è proprio cominciare
a intraprendere un'esplorazione
e i bambini sono
gli esploratori per eccellenza,
perché ogni loro scoperta
porta della conoscenza, porta esperienza.
È un'esplorazione che,
prima di tutto, è geografica,
cioè capire il mondo dove ci troviamo,
dove viviamo, quello che ci sta intorno
e poi diventa cognitiva,
sensoriale, umana e così via.
Questa esplorazione, soprattutto
quando si è bambini, è dettata
da due sentimenti principali di cui
ci ha lasciato una bellissima descrizione
Leonardo da Vinci,
proprio trovandosi all'imboccatura
di una caverna oscura come uno speleologo.
"Subito si destarono in me
due cose:7y paura e desiderio.
Paura per la minacciosa e buia spelonca".
È la paura dell'ignoto,
la paura di ciò che non si conosce,
di qualcosa che potrebbe essere
al di fuori della nostra portata.
"Desiderio per vedere se là dentro
fussi alcuna misteriosa cosa".
Il desiderio di andare oltre,
fare un passo e andare oltre l'orizzonte
e vedere qualcosa che non si conosce,
meravigliarsi per qualcosa
che non abbiamo neanche immaginato.
Ben presto per tutti noi, crescendo,
il desiderio di vedere,
chiaramente ha il sopravvento
sulla paura.
E così è stato anche per me,
già da ragazzino,
nel mio caso si è trattato proprio
di un'esplorazione fisica
nel senso di andare a vedere le grotte
che c'erano sui Monti Lessini,
proprio qui vicino a Verona,
una zona carsica con moltissime cavità.
Una in particolare
da subito mi ha colpito,
molto famosa,
che è la Spluga della Preta,
qui sul Corno d'Aquilio.
Qui vedete il primo pozzo di 130 metri,
una voragine profondissima;
arriva a quasi 900 metri di profondità
sotto la superficie della Terra,
ha uno sviluppo attualmente rilevato,
conosciuto, di circa 8 km.
Ma questa grotta non è tanto importante
per la sua profondità,
il suo sviluppo, i pozzi
meravigliosi al suo interno
quanto per la sua storia;
perché è una storia esemplificativa
e ci spiega
perché gli uomini si avventurano
in questi luoghi così remoti e nascosti
del nostro pianeta.
Tutto cominciò nel 1925, quando
la sezione universitaria del CAI di Verona
decise di affrontare questo buco
che si apriva nei prati
per sondarne le profondità.
Non avevano nessuna esperienza
di speleologia.
Non sapevano cosa avrebbero trovato.
Sapevano che era un buco profondissimo
e pensate che avevano così paura
che scesero con delle rivoltelle,
per essere pronti a sparare a chissà
quali mostri potevano incontrare.
In realtà non incontrarono
nessun mostro particolare,
ma incontrarono soltanto altro ignoto,
cioè l'abisso continuava in profondità
e loro non erano in grado di continuare
perché i loro mezzi a quei tempi non erano
così importanti
come quelli che abbiamo adesso.
Da lì è cominciata tutta un'esplorazione.
Proprio questo ignoto, questo buio
che continuava nelle profondità
ha attirato moltissime persone
un po' da tutto il mondo
a cimentarsi in questa grotta e cercare
di portare avanti il limite esplorativo.
Qui vedete un'immagine della discesa
in scala corda del 1962.
Quella che fu la super spedizione
alla Spluga della Preta organizzata
dal Gruppo Grotte Falchi di Verona.
Ma soprattutto vedete la copertina
della Domenica del Corriere del 1954
che uscì esattamente una settimana dopo
la famosa copertina
della conquista del K2.
Infatti mentre Ardito Desio cercava
di conquistare, con la sua squadra,
la cima della seconda montagna
più alta della Terra,
contemporaneamente, ma fuori
dai riflettori, perché al buio,
gli speleologi italiani
cercavano di conquistare
l'abisso più profondo del mondo.
Tuttavia questo parallelismo tra alpinismo
e speleologia non è del tutto corretto,
in quanto la montagna è un oggetto
che noi possiamo facilmente comprendere,
lo possiamo abbracciare con lo sguardo,
anche senza salirvi sopra,
lo possiamo vedere
con un'immagine satellitare
e soprattutto ogni montagna ha
un limite ben definito, che è la vetta,
oltre la quale non è possibile andare,
c'è solo il cielo.
Per le grotte, se andate
sul Corno d'Aquilio
non vedete la Spluga della Preta,
ma l'ingresso della Spluga della Preta.
La grotta, l'abisso, è un luogo veramente
difficile da comprendere e immaginare.
Tutto quello che conosciamo
è solo quello che abbiamo percorso.
Ciò che non è stato esplorato
rimane nell'oblio, nell'ignoto.
Quindi anche il fondo di una grotta
come la Spluga della Preta.
Il fondo della Spluga che io conosco,
potrebbe tra qualche anno non esserlo più
perché qualcun altro potrebbe arrivare
e guardando nell'oscurità
dove noi non abbiamo visto
individuare un nuovo passaggio
che scende ancora più in profondità.
Quindi la grotta nella sua limitatezza,
l'abisso nella sua limitatezza,
dall'interno del nostro pianeta,
ci dimostra come
l'esplorazione sia infinita.
Non saremo mai in grado
di conoscere tutto quanto.
Anch'io ho avuto la fortuna, nel 2003
di esplorare la Spluga della Preta.
Questo mi ha chiaramente
segnato moltissimo,
proprio il fatto di entrare in un luogo
che prima, di fatto, non esisteva,
non esisteva per l'uomo perché non era
alla portata della conoscenza dell'uomo,
e anche il fatto di meravigliarsi,
di rimanere estasiati di fronte
a queste meraviglie della natura.
Quindi ho iniziato un percorso con il team
di esplorazioni geografiche La Venta
di esplorazioni in giro per i continenti.
Il nostro interesse era anche
capire queste grotte,
come si sviluppano nei vari ambienti,
dalle foreste del Messico, del Chiapas,
del Sud America, delle Filippine,
agli ambienti desertici.
Qui siamo in Uzbekistan.
Grotte a quasi 4000 metri e così via.
Fino ad arrivare all'ultimo progetto,
quello che più mi sta a cuore
in questo momento,
che è l'esplorazione delle grotte
dei tepui venezuelani,
questi massicci che si trovano
tra Venezuela e Brasile,
nella zona della Gran Sabana
e dell'Amazzonia,
che si trovano all'interno
di montagne antichissime,
montagne che hanno 1,6 miliardi di anni.
Le grotte stesse sono le più antiche
che possiamo trovare sul nostro pianeta
e contengono delle forme di vita,
soprattutto batteri,
che sono molto interessanti per capire
l'origine e l'evoluzione della vita
sul nostro pianeta.
Ma un'altra cosa molto importante
che ho imparato in queste esplorazioni
è che la realtà supera sempre
e di gran lunga l'immaginazione.
Cioè, noi possiamo pensare,
immaginare, fantasticare,
come vedete in questa illustrazione
di Giulio Verne del 1864,
che cosa ci potrebbe essere
sotto la superficie della Terra
ma la realtà, quando andremo a scoprire,
supererà sempre la nostra fantasia.
Infatti chissà cosa avrebbe detto
Giulio Verne se avesse visto,
un secolo e mezzo dopo, questa grotta
in Messico, nella miniera di Naica,
la Cueva dei Cristalli giganti di Naica?
Questa è stata scoperta
nei primi anni 2000,
è stata esplorata da La Venta.
È una foresta di cristalli
che arrivano fino a 13 metri di lunghezza
ed è una grotta che ci insegna
una cosa anche molto interessante.
Questa grotta non aveva un accesso
sulla superficie del pianeta,
è stata intercettata
da una galleria mineraria,
quindi è una grotta, una cavità,
più legata alle profondità della Terra
che non alla superficie.
Tutto ciò che conosciamo
del mondo sotterraneo
sostanzialmente sono quelle grotte
che hanno un accesso alla superficie,
sono quelle dove noi possiamo entrare,
ma tutte quelle che invece non hanno
nessun accesso alla superficie
quelle non le conosceremo mai,
se non per caso come in questa situazione.
Quindi chissà quante altre grotte
come quella dei Cristalli,
o chissà quali meraviglie, esistono
che non avremo mai
la possibilità di conoscere
perché non esiste
nessun metodo scientifico, geofisico
che riesca veramente ad andare
a investigare queste cavità sotterranee.
Un'altra cosa molto importante
che ho imparato negli anni di esplorazioni
è che non serve andare lontano
per fare esplorazione.
Non è necessario attraversare gli oceani,
andare in altri continenti
o in luoghi remoti.
L'idea dell'esploratore che abbiamo
soprattutto nel XXI secolo,
e più in generale dal XX secolo,
è quella che l'esploratore
deve andare lontano,
pensiamo a un esploratore in Antartide,
nei deserti dell'Asia,
nei posti più remoti, dove l'uomo
non ha ancora intaccato la natura.
In realtà non è così.
Si può anche esplorare alle porte di casa
ed è quello che fanno
gli speleologi anche qui in Italia.
Adesso vi racconto un paio di storie
per dimostrarvelo,
proprio ambientate qui in Veneto,
in particolare nelle Dolomiti.
Questo che vedete è lo spallone est
del Monte Pelmo, sopra San Vito di Cadore
e questi buchi sulla parete,
che si vedevano anche dal paese,
non erano mai stati raggiunti.
Non ci sono vie alpinistiche
che passano lì vicino.
C'era la curiosità,
soprattutto della gente del paese,
di capire che cosa fossero.
Come La Venta siamo stati invitati
da uno scultore, Mauro "Lampo" Olivotto,
a tentare di scendere la parete,
che è alta circa 1000 metri,
e raggiungere queste grotte in parete.
Quindi un luogo
che veramente è alla portata,
cioè calandoci noi sentivamo le campane
dei paesi sotto della Valle del Boite,
ma che di fatto era estremamente lontano,
mai raggiunto da nessuno.
Le grotte, come vedete,
non sono delle grotte enormi,
non sono grotte lunghe chilometri,
ma non è solo una questione
di un'esplorazione geografica, in metri,
ma anche di capire
cosa c'è al loro interno.
In questo caso ci sono
dei sedimenti antichissimi
che potrebbero dare delle informazioni
sull'evoluzione geografica delle Dolomiti.
Quindi è un'esplorazione
che è anche scoperta
e poi si trasforma
in ricerca scientifica.
Ormai l'esploratore non è più nessuno
senza lo scienziato.
Questo coinvolge non solo
l'ambiente sotterraneo,
ma anche l'ambiente che ci sta intorno.
Pensate che qui sopra proprio mettendo
le corde per effettuare questa calata
abbiamo notato su una lastra di roccia
delle piccole depressioni allineate,
le abbiamo fotografate e subito
abbiamo intuito che potessero essere
delle impronte di dinosauro.
Sono attualmente in studio
da parte dell'Università di Padova
e sono tra le più alte impronte
di dinosauro mai scoperte nelle Alpi.
Qui vedete una scultura di Mauro "Lampo"
che ha voluto omaggiare
le impronte delle Dolomiti.
Un'altra storia interessante, più recente.
Qui vedete l'elicottero che sta partendo
per allestire un campo sul Piz Conturines
nel Parco Naturale di Fanes-Senes-Braies.
Nell'ottobre del 2015
abbiamo organizzato questa spedizione
in collaborazione
tra vari gruppi veneti e La Venta
per risolvere un mistero
che è cominciato nel 1994.
Vedete questo laghetto alpino
a quasi 3000 metri di quota?
Nel '94, in una notte,
si svuotò improvvisamente.
Il laghetto era una depressione
che poggiava su un ghiacciaio sotterraneo
che si è probabilmente sciolto in parte,
forse per i cambiamenti climatici attuali
e ha risucchiato tutta l'acqua
lasciando aperto un pertugio nel ghiaccio
che scendeva
verso chissà quali profondità.
È stata un'esplorazione molto difficile,
condotta inizialmente
dal Club Speleologico Proteo di Vicenza,
attraverso un dedalo
di condotti ghiacciati
che possono essere affrontati
solo in determinati periodi dell'anno,
in quanto lo scioglimento del ghiaccio
alimenta dei torrenti interni
che altrimenti non permettono
l'esplorazione.
Nel 2010 abbiamo superato il tappo
di ghiaccio di circa 100 metri di spessore
e siamo riusciti a entrare
in una sala gigantesca,
che attualmente è la sala sotterranea
più grande mai scoperta nelle Dolomiti.
Quest'anno, nel 2015, siamo tornati
per riuscire a portare fuori
qualche informazione in più
di questa cattedrale sotterranea,
per capirne veramente le dimensioni.
Per fare questo abbiamo utilizzato
un laser scanner,
una strumentazione molto avanzata
che permette di ottenere
un modello 3D dell'ambiente.
Qui siamo appesi a 110 metri di altezza
con questo strumento.
Una spedizione anche molto rocambolesca;
il tecnico del laser scanner
era abbastanza spaventato,
ma alla fine ne è uscito
molto contento.
Quello che vedete adesso
in questo video è un po' il risultato.
(Musica)
Vedete noi scansionati sulla destra,
sulla piattaforma.
Questa scansione ci ha permesso di capire
che questa cattedrale sotterranea
è alta circa 210 metri,
ha un volume di mezzo milione
di metri cubi,
di poco inferiore
alla cattedrale di San Pietro.
Questa scansione ci permetterà
anche in futuro
di capire come sta evolvendo il ghiaccio
all'interno di questa cavità
perché il ghiacciaio interno ha registrato
i cambiamenti climatici globali
di migliaia di anni fa
e attualmente sta registrando
quelli attuali.
Quindi avere un confronto per il futuro
sarà estremamente importante
per capire cosa sta succedendo
nel cuore delle Dolomiti adesso.
(Musica)
Troppo spesso pensiamo
che non ci sia più niente da esplorare.
Abbiamo relegato l'idea dell'ignoto
a pianeti lontani,
a galassie, all'universo.
Ma questo succede soltanto
perché vivendo sulla Terra da adulti
abbiamo perso quella sensibilità
alla paura e al desiderio verso l'ignoto
che avevamo da bambini.
È sufficiente cambiare la nostra visione,
non dare mai nulla per scontato,
e ci accorgeremo che c'è ancora tantissimo
da scoprire e esplorare anche sulla Terra.
Non serve andare lontano,
non serve attraversare gli oceani,
per potersi meravigliare,
per poter scoprire qualcosa di nuovo.
Le esplorazioni sono
anche qui alle porte di casa.
È sufficiente mettersi
questi occhi da bambini,
guardare la Terra
come fa un esploratore
e forse, meravigliandoci, avremo anche
più riguardo per il nostro pianeta Terra
e potremo continuare
a meravigliarci della natura
conservandola e proteggendola.
Grazie.
(Applausi)